mass incarceration makes our country
worse off and we need to do something
about it for nonviolent drug crimes we
need to lower long mandatory minimum
sentences or get rid of them entirely we
should not be tolerating overcrowding in
prison we should not be tolerating gang
activity in prison we should not be
tolerating rape in prison and we
shouldn't be making jokes about it in
our popular culture that's no joke
these things are unacceptable do we
really think it makes sense to lock so
many people alone in tiny cells for 23
hours a day for months sometimes for
years at a time that is not going to
make us safer let's follow the growing
number of our states and cities and
private companies who decided to ban the
bucks on job applications so that former
prisoners who have done their time and
are now trying to get straight with
society have a decent shot in a job
interview and if folks have served their
time and they've reenter society
I should be able to vote